right now it's that weird process the
best way that I can describe it is like
grieving the loss of parents who are
still alive Savannah Chrisley emotional
in the days leading up to her parents
prison sentencing after they were found
guilty of conspiracy to commit bank
fraud
IA roll the toilet paper we signed up
for a show that has entertained millions
and millions and millions of people but
what we didn't sign up for is to be lied
on on Monday Savannah's dad Todd was
sentenced to 12 years and Mom Julie
seven years when you're watching this
episode you'll be watching it on Tuesday
November 22nd and the 21st is when we go
to court for sentencing and on the
latest episode of Savannah's podcast
that was recorded before the Chrisleys
learned their fate she describes the
personal toll the scandal's taken on her
I've
lost weight I'm not really eating I mean
I couldn't tell you the last time I've
actually worked out I'm just feeling
down but I think I've been in such a
deep depression I've never seen two
people my parents be so steadfast in
their faith that Savannah speaking
exclusively to E.T last week in the end
the truth will prevail may get harder
before it gets easier but we have faith
these were very serious crimes the fraud
was extensive I think these sentences
were pretty much within the range of
what one would expect and obviously for
those that aren't familiar with the
legal system the sentencing has to
happen first in order for you to file
for an appeal and well immediately be
doing that meanwhile Savannah is not the
only sibling getting feelings off her
chest her older sister Lindsay is too
I'm a fun kind of person oh God Mindy
and her dad were previously estranged
but they reconciled in the wake of
Todd's conviction she is my daughter and
I love her things haven't always been
peachy and we've had to fight our
battles publicly Monday night after the
sentences were announced Lindsay posted
this video to her Instagram story The
caption hints that she's leaning on her
friends in the aftermath my mom's taught
me that
we're gonna pray for everyone
we're we're gonna pray for the
prosecutors we're going to pray for the
judge and like I said this is just for
the short term
I mean we file for an appeal and by the
grace of God
Our Truth
wins in June Todd and Julie were in
court facing charges for bank fraud and
tax evasion and after a three-week trial
the couple was convicted on all counts
one of the things that the courts are
supposed to take into account when they
sentence is the deterrent effect the
sentence that's given is essentially
serving as a warning to deter them from
committing crimes and when it comes to
things like bank fraud tax evasion and
things that the Chrisleys were convicted
of
there's a sense in the legal community
and among judges and prosecutors that
those crimes really can be deterred it's
sending a message to the community at
large that these crimes are noticed that
these crimes do not go unpunished